-(CROWD CHEERING)
-ANNOUNCER: It's showtime!
RODNEY BARNES:
The year is 1979,
and the Los Angeles Lakers
are, if you can believe it,
a down-and-out team.
JERRY BUSS: Welcome
to sunny Los Angeles.
Great for tans,
shit for fans.
RODNEY: But the new owner
has a vision.
JERRY: If there's two things
that make me believe in God,
it's sex and basketball.
RODNEY: Welcome to
the world of Winning Time,
the new HBO series
about the rise
of the Lakers dynasty.
ANNOUNCER 2: First pick
of the 1979 NBA draft,
the Los Angeles Lakers
select
Earvin "Magic" Johnson.
RODNEY: I'm Rodney Barnes,
an executive producer
and writer on the show,
and the host of
the official Winning Time
companion podcast
from HBO,
Hyperobject Industries,
and Pineapple Street
Studios.
Over the next ten weeks,
I'll be breaking down
each episode
of Winning Time,
taking you
behind the scenes,
and talking shop
and basketball
with the show's creators,
stars and collaborators.
Everyone from
executive producer
and director, Adam McKay...
ADAM MCKAY: When you get
that fast-break,
freewheeling,
creative style going,
it's much harder
to game plan against.
So these teams
started winning
and they were winning
with style and flair.
And right in the middle
of that
were the Showtime Lakers.
RODNEY: ...to showrunner
Max Borenstein...
MAX BORENSTEIN: I hope that
one of the things
people come away with
is not just an appreciation
for the people
that they know,
the Magics, the Kareems,
the Pat Rileys,
but knowing and respecting
and having
a new appreciation
for the characters
and the people
that they've never heard of.
RODNEY:
...to the breakout star who
plays Magic Johnson himself,
Quincy Isaiah.
QUINCY ISAIAH:
I feel like sometimes,
I have to remind myself
like, "Yo, you doing this.
You here because
you deserve to be here."
If I feel like an imposter,
all right, well,
let's work until I'm not.
RODNEY: And along the way,
we'll learn how the Lakers
came to be the center
of sports and celebrity
in 1980s LA.
JERRY:
If you're a human being
with two eyes and heart,
this game, this industry
makes you feel good.
JESSIE BUSS:
What industry? Sweat socks?
JERRY: No. Show business!
MAGIC JOHNSON:
It's going to be exciting.
RODNEY:
Winning Time: The Rise
of the Lakers' Dynasty
premieres Sunday, March 6th
on HBO Max.
Episode one of this podcast
drops right after that.
Be sure to subscribe to
Winning Time: The Official
Companion Podcast.
New episodes drop
every Sunday.
Get them on HBO Max
or wherever you listen.